[music playing]
RANDY: Woke up in a bit
of a mood this morning.
Bit of a poor me
situation going on.
I just-- you know, it's
been going back and forth
and back and forth now.
But I think today I
really hit a wall.
[music playing]
So I'm going to go out
and do some fishing
and see if I can feel better.
It's really snowing.
[music playing]
There's no fish.
They're just not there anymore.
They were there, and then all
of a sudden, they weren't.
There's been a direct
correlation between temperature
and food production.
It was like something that
just happened overnight.
One second there was tons
of food, and then the next,
wasn't anymore.
At this point, it's
been about a week
since I've caught any
fish, and no grouse.
The greens are wilted, and I'm
not seeing deer scat or a sign
around.
So I'm absolutely feeling
anxious, just not knowing where
my next meal is coming from.
[music playing]
Five weeks I walked here.
Walked all up and
down my territory.
In solitude.
Eating only what
the land provided.
Lack of food and lack of
companionship at this point
is really sort of
taking its toll on me.
And in all honesty,
I'm struggling.
No matter where I'm at, I
actively search out community.
I think that that's one
of the things that's
been so hard for me
out here is that I
have no sense of community.
With community, comes
a sense of place.
Without community, there's
a huge part of my world
that's missing.
And I wish that I could pull
it from the environment.
In some ways, I
have been, but it's
a temporary fix, like putting
a Band-Aid on a bullet hole.
I was looking forward to pushing
myself past that barrier.
I want to continue going.
[music playing]
I just don't want to do
it without anybody else.
This is Randy.
I'm officially tapping out.
I'm ready to go home.
[music playing]
What's going on?
I haven't been able to
produce really any food.
And set up a lot
of traps, and those
weren't producing as well.
But there's a whole other aspect
to me that's not being fed up
here, and that is my lack of
social interaction with people
and my lack of community.
It's difficult.
It's been difficult.
You know, I've reached the end
of my time here in Mongolia.
[music playing]
In a lot of ways, this
place has pulled me in
and made me feel at home.
Kept me warm, fairly well-fed
for the first couple of weeks.
Kept me company.
When I left Vancouver,
I felt like I didn't
fully do what I wanted to do.
This feels like it's
time and feels right.
Going beyond 21 days was
in some way a goal for me.
I wanted to last longer
than I lasted in Vancouver,
and so I feel like this
was a redemption for me.